welches wasser trinkt ihr halt nicht
zuhause leitungswasser oder
mineralwasser aus dem supermarkt bevor
ich in diese wohnung hier gezogen bin
habe ich eigentlich immer nur
leitungswasser getrunken nur dieses
leitungswasser schmeckt mir nicht
das war im sommer inzwischen bin ich
wieder um gestiegen und habe mir während
dessen viele gedanken zu leitungswasser
gemacht praktischerweise kann ich da ein
paar leute die sich sehr gut mit
leitungswasser ausgehen dass ins wenn
anna und patrick die drei arbeiten im
zentrallabor von hessenwasser ihr job
ist es die qualität des leitungswassers
im rhein main gebiet sicherzustellen
dass wenn man erkenne ich schon länger
die haben damals zusammen in mainz
chemie studiert und viel gemeinsam mit
zeit im labor verbracht jetzt habe ich
sie mal in ihrem labor besucht ich will
in diesem video folgende fragen stellen
wie gut ist das deutsche leitungswasser
was ist mit schwermetallen mit
krankheitserregern was ist mit mikro
plastik oder medikamenten resten wir
verschaffen uns den durchblick ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass es so einiges
gibt es ihr nicht zur leitungswasser
willst also selbst euch macht es euch
bequem hole ich ihn klar seit ins wasser
wohl auch nicht bevor es ans eingemachte
geht erst mal ein paar basics unser
leitungs und trinkwasser kommt aus
verschiedenen quellen also aus
buchstäblichen quellen aber auch aus
talsperren und vor allem aus grundwasser
wenn leitungswasser nicht schmeckt dann
kann das natürlich am persönlichen
geschmack liegen aber auch am
mineralgehalt der mineralgehalt kann je
nach quelle des wassers unterschiedlich
hoch sein und dazu zählt auch die
wasserhärte also der kalkgehalt das sind
vor allen dingen hätte bilden also
mineral das sind kalzium und magnesium
zu nennen wir werden aus dem gestein
gelöst kalkstein im untergrund das heißt
es fällt regen der regen ist mit co2
versetzt
das bildet dann im untergrund
kohlensäure und diese kohlensäure löst
das kalkgestein auf und das fördern wir
damit unseren
wiederum das finden wir dann auch
letztendlich für uns im trinkwasser
wieder
es ist aber ungesund hat das wasser zu
trinken grundsätzlich passiert gar
nichts also wenn wir viel kalzium zu uns
nehmen dann reicht es immer noch nicht
aus um den nährstoffhaushalt damit zu
decken nur eben in unserem wasserkocher
in den kochtöpfen kann es nervig werden
aber lässt sich auf jeden fall wieder
beheben und nicht gesundheitsschädlich
damit ihr so ein gefühl dafür bekommt
mit nur 100 gramm emmentalerkäse nimmt
bereits genauso viel kalzium und
magnesium zu sich die mit einem zehn
liter eimer wasser halten kann man jede
schon mal nicht hat das wasser kann
sogar seine vorteile haben häufig rufen
leute bei uns an die sich über metalle
in ihrem trinkwasser sorgen machen
meistens ist die frage nach frei und da
ist wiederum kalk im wasser eine gute
sache denn sie bildet eine schutzschicht
in der rohrleitung die wiederum
verhindert dass sich metalle aus der aus
der rohrleitung in das wasser hinein
lösen können
vor allem bei blei liegt der erlaubte
grenzwert tief denn blei ist ein
nervengift und besonders gefährlich für
schwangere und kleinkinder wird immer
weise wurden früher wasserleitungen aus
blei verlegt heute zum glück nicht mehr
bleirohre kann es nur noch in häusern
geben mit einem baujahr vor 1973
untersuchen sehr häufig für die leute
hier ihre trinkwasser installationen auf
eben blei und weitere metalle wie zum
beispiel zink und eisen und es kommt
ganz selten vor dass mal der grenzwert
überschritten wird
falls ihr euch aber doch unsicher seid
mit schwermetallen im leitungswasser
dann kriegt ihr die infos entweder bei
eurem zuständigen gesundheitsamt oder
bei eurem lokalen
wasserversorgungsunternehmen
hausbesitzer und wasserversorger sind
übrigens dazu verpflichtet drei jahre
auszutauschen wenn der grenzwert
überschritten wird okay aber das
gruselige an leitungswasser ist doch
dass dieses wasser bevor es aus dem
wasserhahn rauskommt durch ein riesiges
rohrleitungssystem fließt
dass ich nicht sehen kann was ich was in
den tiefen dieser rohre da herum kriecht
und wächst man darf sich das aber gar
nicht so vorstellen dass das wasser
darin die ganze zeit steht also in den
hausleitungen ist halt wirklich so dass
das wasser fliesst konstanz also es ist
weit es wird immer irgendwo was
verbraucht zur not werden halt auch rufe
gespült tatsächlich künstlich um halt
genau das eben zu gewährleisten
also dem haupt wassernetz ist das wasser
immer in bewegung um genau das zu
verhindern was man sich eben vorstellt
weil es das dort halt eben irgendwie
leben entsteht oder leben wächst
stehende gewässer sind viel einladen
dafür mikrobiologisches leben als
fließendes wasser hinzu kommt dass in
unserem wasserleitungen auch ganz ohne
ist keine luft und auch wenig nährstoffe
also unterm strich schlechte bedingungen
für leben als muss man sich klar machen
steril ist dieses wasser nicht in diesem
glas auf meiner haut auf meinen
klamotten überall leben ganz viele
mikroorganismen aber die sind habe los
damit sie unter diese harmlosen
mikroorganismen nicht doch mal
bösewichte mission wie zum beispiel
durch war erreger gibt es inzwischen
auch immer bessere nachweismethoden um
die qualität des wassers zu
gewährleisten und falls ihr doch mal
länger nicht daheim watt und bedenken
habe dass das wasser in den
rohrleitungen jetzt schon länger stand
gibt es in ganz einfachen trick haben
aufdrehen das wasser laufen lassen
und sobald man mit dem finger merkt es
wird in bedeutend kälter dann kann man
das auf jeden fall bedenkenlos trinken
jetzt sollte uns aber mal gedanken
machen nicht um das wasser das aus dem
wasser heraus kommt sondern auch um das
wasser das in den abschluss rhein fließt
alles was wird den abfluss runterspülen
gelandet in den kläranlagen und alles
was in den kläranlagen nicht geklärt
werden kann landet in der natur in
letzter zeit reden alle über mikro
plastik also kleinste plastik partikel
der großteil des micro plastiks kommt
von großem plastik also plastikmüll der
leider tonnenweise über unsere flüsse in
die meere gelangt und dort mit der zeit
weiß ich dass ich eben nicht zersetzt
einfach kleingeräten wird bis es micro
plastik partikel sind die mit der zeit
auch wieder in unsere nahrungskette land
aber wir spielen auch mikro plastik
unseren abschluss herunter und zwar
nicht nur über kosmetikartikel
unsere kleidung besteht ganz ganz wenig
nur aus baumwolle also aus natürlichen
stoffen sondern die meisten kleinen die
wir tragen besteht zum beispiel aus
polyester zumindest aus anteil von
polyester oder anderen synthetischen
fasern gerade weil funktionskleidung
aber auch bei dem t shirt was wir jeden
tag tragen sind eben synthetische fasern
enthalten die dann eben zum größten teil
in der waschmaschine aus der kleidung
ausgetragen werden und so in unser
abwasser gelangen können und damit auch
wieder in unsere flüsse aber wieviel
micro plastik landet da jetzt genau anna
ist analytikerin dann stellt sich ja mal
vor dass chemiker im labor nur sachen
herstellen aber anna macht was anderes
sie analysiert und charakterisiert und
das ist überhaupt nicht trivial
ja wenn ich stoffen mit bloßem auge
nicht sehen kann wie soll ich
herausfinden was ich hier vorliegen
haben dazu braucht man gewitzte
physikalische und chemische messmethode
aber gerade bei micro plastik ist das
gar nicht so einfach wenn wir uns jetzt
vorstellen
uns interessiert wie viel micro plastik
ist denn jetzt in unserem
oberflächenwasser also im fluss
enthalten
wir nehmen also mehrere liter
oberflächenwasser und haben dann eine
sammlung aus den micro plastik partikeln
aus allem was da sonst noch so in rom
stimmt also auch natürlichen stoffen
holzstückchen steinchen algen wir müssen
erstmal diese plastik artikel von diesen
anderen partikeln trennen als kardashian
denken mit einem einfachen sieg oder
filter funktioniert es nicht zumal es
auch so viele verschiedene plastik
sorten gibt noch was also wenn ich im
labor sitze und möchte eine probe an
analysieren untersuchen kann es schon
sein dass mein oberteil in dem er
synthetische fasern sind meine probe
kontaminiert also am ende sehe ich
irgendwie im mikroskop da eine
synthetikfasern die ist aber gar nicht
aus der probe bekommen sondern von mir
also man muss sehr reine bedingungen
auch im labor schaffen in kleinen stadt
kein problem im großen maßstab ist ricky
beschäftigt sich seit seiner
doktorarbeit mit analytik er warte noch
vor was andere auf gar keinen fall
medikamente die toilette runterspülen
genau aus dem grund
ja es ist das ist tatsächlich immer noch
ein allgemeines problem
ja das ist für viele leute meinen hut
ich kann ja mal in meinem posten saft
oder meine nicht aufgebrauchten pillen
einfach die leute runter und dann sind
sie weg
die lösen sich darin auf und am ende
gibt es halt wieder in den
wasserkreislauf zurück und das problem
ist halt eben das wirklich ein paar von
diesen von den inhaltsstoffen sehr
unzureichend bis gar nicht abgebaut
werden auf dem weg wobei man hier wie so
oft auch nicht verallgemeinern kann
medikament ist nicht gleich medikament
das schmerzmittel aspirin zum beispiel
das lässt sich biologisch recht leicht
abbauen
das schmerzmittel diclofenac allerdings
das ist in wollte rehn und anderen seien
drin oder auch in tabletten
das lässt sich biologisch nicht so
leicht abbauen selbst im körper wird es
nur teilweise verstoffwechselt der rest
wird unverändert ausgeschieden
dann also in der toilette runtergespült
lange aber auch natürlich auch über die
dusche wenn ich mir das als salbe
irgendwo drauf schmiere
natürlich auch da geht nun ganz geringer
prozentsatz wirklich dann in die haut
und wird halt irgendwie irgendwie
verwendet der rest wird einfach
abgespült landet halt wieder im abwasser
und kommt in die kläranlage lange also
am ende wieder der natur unverändert die
biologische abbaubarkeit ist es eine die
so genannte mobilität ist das andere
wenn ein stoff jetzt zum beispiel sehr
polaris sprich er versteht sich gut mit
wasser denn wie dieser stoff leicht mit
dem wasser mitgetragen und ja auf der
ganzen welt verteilt es gibt bereits
studien die halt auch von menschen
gemachte substanzen halt auch im
gletschereis finden oder in der
antarktis und und weil es sind genau
solche substanzen dann wirklich über den
ganzen erdball am ende verteilt werden
und so auch ein ökologisches problem
sein können bevor jetzt denkt 'oh mein
gott' konzentrationen die analytiker wie
sven oder anna im labor feststellen
können sind winzig klein und die
messtechniken haben sich in diesem
bereich auch stark weiterentwickelt
zwischen sehr großen wie vor zum
beispiel den bodensee
baden württemberg und wenn ich dort
einen zuckerwürfel einen ganz normalen
zuckerwürfel in diesen sehr schmeißen
würde von der substanz könnte ich den
nachweisen
das ist der mikrogramm euro nanogramm
pro liter bereich und wir kommen noch
viel weiter runter und dazwischen das
ist so dass ich bin ich von diesen
zuckerwürfel noch noch klein hohe und 1
zuckerkristalle letztendlich neben den
in den bodensee schmeiße dann kann ich
den immer noch nachweisen aber je länger
wie ein stoff in die natur einbringen
desto mehr läuft er sich daran
deswegen auf gar keinen fall medikamente
sie toilette spülen vorsicht ist besser
als nachsicht gibt eventuell auch
substanzen die wir in die natur
einbringen von dem wir noch gar nicht
wissen dass wir ein problem sind die
dann in der zukunft eventuell an ein
problem sein können weil wir das in
wissenschaftlichen studien dann
irgendwann untermauern können dass das
was wir vielleicht für die ganze zeit
als als unschädlich teuren problematisch
gehalten haben in zukunft irgendwann mal
ein problem sein könnte und wie alt das
jetzt noch gar nicht auf dem schirm
haben anstatt zu warten bis ein neuer
kritischer stoffe identifiziert wird
oder bis irgendwelche grenzwerte
überschritten sind versucht es wenn
jetzt schon stoffe und konzentration zu
beobachten und so die analytik
vorausschauend einzusetzen prävention
statt reaktion zu hause trinken die drei
natürlich auch leitungswasser ich
trinkwasser meinen persönlichen sprudler
immer von zu hause aus ich wohne auch im
vierten stock also dann muss ich auch
keine kisten mehr schleppen aber
durchaus also seitdem ich weiß wie
strenges kontrolliert wird sehe ich gar
keine veranlassung mehr normales
abgepacktes wasser zu kaufen
gesundheitlich ist es 102 aus
ökologischer sicht ist ganz klar besser
am ende ist es eine geschmacks wahl und
deutschland haben wir die
trinkwasserverordnung und die ist eine
der strengsten reglementierungen wie wir
sie kennen und das sorgt sie dafür dass
unser trinkwasser auch um welten besser
ist als es ist kann ich nicht sagen
er sagt wir so um welten besser ist ein
wissen übertrieben aber im globalen
vergleich ist das deutsche
leitungswasser ganz vorne mit dabei das
deutsche leitungswasser unterliegt
strengeren qualitätskriterien als das
mineralwasser im supermarkt steckt viel
arbeit sorgfalt und wissenschaft hinter
qualität dieses wassers dass wir zu
hause einfach so aus unserem hahn
bekommen und ich finde dass es ein
privileg das wertschätzen sollen
prost welche fragen sind für euch jetzt
noch offen und findet ihr es gut wenn
wir in zukunft mehr experteninterviews
schreibe es in die kommentare und nicht
weggehen
ich hab auch ne coole and kartellamt
somit bekommen über social media mir
wurde der georg von holtzbrinck preis
für wissenschaftsjournalismus überreicht
und ich möchte euch etwas zeigen von der
preisverleihung nämlich meine laudatio
ulrich guten teil vom deutschlandfunk
hat mein laudatio gehalten und anstatt
eine rede zu halten hat er ein video
gemacht und das obwohl er zuvor noch nie
ein video geschnitten hatte und es ist
der hammer jedes meile video sich
angeschaut
er hat sich das schneiden selbst
angeeignet ich weiß nicht ob sich jemals
jemand schon so viel mühe seine laudatio
gemacht hat und das video ist so geil
geworden schaut es euch an wir haben es
um gelistet verlinkt das obere video ist
es geht hin und hinterlasst uli
blumenthal ein paar kekse für seine mühe
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag bis
dahin bleibt sicher